is the first explosive moment of the
Hamza Yusuf Premiership here in Scotland
that news in the last few minutes that
Kate Forbes his main leadership rival in
that very bitter contest to replace
Nicholas sturgeon has rejected a
demotion within his newly formed cabinet
a cabinet that is still being put
together and shaped as we speak we
understand that Kate Forbes was offered
the demotion from Finance secretary in
charge of Scotland's economy to the
reduced possession of rural Affairs
secretary that was something we're told
she swiftly declined she has resigned
from the Scottish government and will
return to the back benches there is no
doubt this is a huge blow for Hamza
Yusuf and does not go a great deal
towards healing those Rifts that have
been endured for the SNP over the course
of the last couple of weeks it was a
really tough better contest between
Hamza Yusuf and Kate Forbes let's
remember tens of thousands of SMP
supporters voted for Cape Forbes during
that contest uh she got 48 of the vote
overall and it was one of the big tasks
for Hamza Yusuf how will he reunite that
party and bring Kate Forbes into the
fold well tonight we know that is not
happening and that will be a big moment
for the thousands of SMP supporters who
did back that moment for change they
said continuity will not cut it and
tonight Kate Forbes is gone this has
been a day of procedure here at holyroot
with Hamza Yusuf formally being voted in
as the next first Minister as a real
moment watching his uh predecessor
Nicholas sturgeon sitting on those back
benches in this building behind me and
here's a flavor of what he had to say in
that victory speech
after 9 11 were not easy for Muslims
growing up in Scotland or indeed across
the UK I've lost count of how many times
my identity my loyalty to Scotland the
only country I have ever and will ever
call home has been questioned over the
years
there was a time not all that long ago
when I fell I simply did not belong here
in Scotland
to grow to go from there to now leading
the government as Scotland's sixth first
Minister I hope sends a strong message
to every single person out there who
feels that they don't belong and as
first Minister I will always fight for
your rights and where possible I will do
everything I can to advance them
significant policy issues for Hamza
Yusuf who we just watched giving that
speech how will he tackle the quandary
of Independence furthering that cause
that Nicholas sturgeon has not done
during the course of her more than 3 000
days in office it's understood uh Mr
Youssef will be speaking to the prime
minister in the coming hours for that
first conversation I asked Mr Youssef
the new first Minister earlier on
whether Independence would be brought up
in that conversation and it would not be
a surprise to tell you that that will be
forming part of those talks but it is
the moment Kate Forbes not being part of
this new era this new government here in
Scotland she will be joining Nicholas
sturgeon on the back benches